Fortnite og ist vor einigen Wochen
rausgekommen ich habe davon irgendwie
jetzt erst mitbekommen von daher
schicken wir Laser Luca 69 mit seinem
komischen hässlichen Hund mal wieder in
den Kampf niemand kann mich jetzt
[Musik]
stoppen
es geht los Freunde wir gehen wieder
rein in den Fight sind wieder in tilted
gelandet haben direkt hier eine Kiste
vor uns und keinen anderen direkt das
Pack hier mal hinchmeißen zack zack hab
ein bisschen extra Leben und jetzt
schauen wir mal direkt ob hier irgendwer
landet oh 10 Sekunden
später wir gehen diesmal nicht hier
rechts nach tilted Tower sondern ganz
entspannt zum pleasant Park da vorne ich
bin einfach in Fortnite nicht so der
Mensch der krass am rasieren ist wenn er
direkt ins Gefecht kommt mit dem ganzen
Stress umgehen kann erst recht nicht
wenn ich krank
bin wer hat sich eigentlich ausgedacht
dass diese Powerfrucht ist die alles
heilt wenn man erkältet
ist
ist ja auch nicht mE eine Frucht das ist
einfach eine Wurzel also keine Ahnung
egal wir machen ganz entspannt ich lande
hier vorne in dem häusilein hin auch
kein Mensch direkt eine blaue Waffe se
was ist das oh die ist ja ganz komisch
na ja okay schauen wir mal weiter haben
wir hier pa Patronen Ken wir erstmal
nichtbuchen Granaten auch nicht hier
haben wir noch eine blau Waffe sehr
schön eigentlich sehr gut ausgerüstet
bisher guck mal unten hier vorne wie das
heiß irgendwie Drink hier vorne haben
wir
sturmdreher
[Musik]
schauen wir mal hier vorne im Haus rum
ob wir hier
eventuell die Tür ist
[Musik]
offen das heißt hier sind irgendwo
welche
[Musik]
besser kannst nicht laufen hier vorne
ist noch so ein saufkrug saufen können
wir ja
deswegen
zitronente boah nicht lecker aber gut
okay den saufk haben wir drin was haben
wir hier vorne noch eine Stein
steinstoßpistole
[Musik]
okay das nicht gut
das ist H gerade nicht
gut das sieht gar nicht gut
aus aber wir sind wieder bei 100
Leben und ich h
Schüsse irgendwo hier ist
[Musik]
jemand
wo wird der abgeschossen von
da geht ab da müssen wir wir haben
volles
Leben sind gut
ausgerüstet von
wo
und die Zone ist auch wieder auf unserer
Seite oh mein
Gott
Cristiano
Ronaldo ich wde
[Musik]
abgeschossen
ich frage mich mittlerweile ob das Bots
sind oder echte
Gegner was der
noch wo ist er hin wo ist er
hin nein ist er das da
hinten man das H me Neill sein
können
verdammt alle so quick lebendig ne er
sammelt da unten gerade irgendwelche
Sachen ein da vorne liegt auch noch
einiges es leben nur noch fünf Leute das
heißt ich und vier andere ich weiß dass
da vorne irgendwo einer ist das war ja
auch ein Busch den hatten wir
abgeschossen der versteckt sich hier
vorne irgendwo da bei dem LKW ich weiß
dass hier in tilted wahrscheinlich
welche sind in den Hochhäusern und hier
unten Schildt halt einer halt den Baum
abschießen aber ich habe jetzt auch
nicht so viel Munition wir haben
eigentlich einen super Spot ich meine
wir sind direkt am Rand der Zone plus
haben hier so ein bisschen high
groundround weil sich hier in diesem
Bereich gleich das
Amen ich bei meiner Fortnite Leistung
ehrlich gesagt noch nie so wirklich
sagen das
Wort ich sicher mir highgound hier vorne
ich gehe hinter diesen
Stein da unten wird nämlich keiner mehr
sein sonst hätte er sich schon hier hin
bewegt die anderen haben gerade irgendwo
geschossen und tiltet heiß ich bin in
der Zone die müssen e gleich
hierherkommen plus ich habe noch ein
taschenriss ja ich habe noch ja ja ich
habe noch ein taschenr da links da links
ist
[Musik]
er okay scheiß drauf